let's bring our headliner today Health
and Human Services Secretary Alex azar
mr. secretary good morning and welcome
good morning good to be with you I've
definitely a lot to get to with you here
first I know that you have a new
announcement to make on the ongoing
preparations being made what exactly is
that
well we're bringing in the grand
princess it's going to dock today as
well as start offloading passengers from
that ship they're gonna be offloaded in
a way that protects first and foremost
the community and secondly protects
those individuals they'll be in an
isolation can quarantine environment
they will then go to facilities that
we've arranged around the country for
their own care they will be tested
they'll go into 14 day quarantine we're
gonna be leaving the crew onboard the
ship although we're surging medical
staff we already have put people on
board the ship to isolate those
individuals make sure appropriate
isolation and quarantine is happening on
board that ship and we're working very
closely with Governor Newsome and the
mayor of Oakland on all of these efforts
there's criticism obviously of the
federal effort here and I just want to
get from you do you feel like your
department that the federal government
and your department have their arms
around this crisis we've been on this
from day one when we first got word from
the China CDC about this and have been
working aggressively to prepare this
country for what we see as a very
serious public health threat we'll take
all actions necessary to protect the
American people working with our state
and local partners we have gotten we've
gotten a diagnostic out there that
diagnostic is in the field it's
available for our public health labs our
labs our hospitals so over a million
shipped over the weekend we now have 2.1
million available for use in the United
States so testing is fully available to
our providers we've got--we've rapid
work on a vaccine that should go into
clinical trials very soon we have a
therapeutic already in clinical trials
we've taken historically aggressive
border could patrol and border control
measures to protect the American people
and we're gonna keep taking very
aggressive steps to protect America
secretary there's a lot to break down
there as far as the vaccine and the
timing of that vaccine because there
also seems to be mixed communication on
that
if I could turn everyone's attention to
the Dow because we've been watching the
US stock market since it opened for
trading just over an hour ago and right
now there is a significant sell-off
happening on Wall Street more than a
five percent drop on the Dow it is a one
thousand three hundred and eighty point
drop due in part to coronavirus fears so
does the administration feel like it has
put out a confident message and a-one
easily understood by the American public
to limit those fears because they are
significantly playing out in our stock
market this morning so president Trump
has delivered a historically strong
economy whether it's on unemployment
numbers or on productivity and he's
going to keep doing that but his number
one concern across the whole of
government along with Vice President
President Pence is leading the public
health preparedness and response effort
here our economic team will work on
economic aspects of this and president
Trump having delivered the best economy
in modern history has the tools and
knows the tools to keep this economy
going
his first focus is public health did he
have anything to say about that stock
market sell-off this morning I haven't
spoken to the president yet this morning
the president in the air right now as we
understand it having just taken off from
West Palm Beach a little while ago
listen Governor Andrew Cuomo obviously
Democrat of New York has been critical
of the federal effort here's what he
told Maria Bartiromo
look testing is limited and this is I
think Maria one of the main issues we
have both in reality and in perception
when you wonder why people are so
anxious and the fear it's because the
information they're getting tends to
change and they're getting mixed
messages how do you answer that last
part in particular mixed messages says
governor for well you know listen I I'm
disturbed by that comment because
Governor Cuomo has actually been a
really good partner working with us so
I'm I'm confused by what he's saying
there because New York State and New
York City have all the lab tests they've
asked for in fact we've offered them
more and they've refused further
shipments of lab tests so there's just
no factual basis for what he's saying
there but he's been a good partner and
we're working really closely with the
New York City Public Health Department
as well as with New York State we
actually approved last over a week I
think a week and a half ago we approved
New York maybe a week ago New York
State's a lab test that they developed
and that we actually approve so they've
been up and running with capacity for
any need they've had let me really be
really clear about one point there has
never been a time since the CDC
developed the lab test that any public
health official in the United States who
needed to get somebody tested for the
novel coronavirus has been unable to get
that person tested through the CDC's
test in Atlanta we have had capacity and
throughput at every moment since we
developed this test that is a fact
secretary a czar Fox News is just now
reporting that the White House has made
the decision to limit certain in-person
meetings because of the growing spread
of the virus according to a senior
administration official the White House
and the State Department are
discouraging foreign officials from
coming to visit instead opting for phone
calls and videoconferences when possible
can you confirm that well III don't have
all the details I'm sitting here with
you as any announcement like that's been
made but we're gonna take steps just
like private industry to ensure
protection of our people and to mitigate
the spread of disease take appropriate
reasonable steps you know we're working
right now the CDC is imbedded in the
state of Washington with Governor Inslee
and in California with santa clara
county where we're advising them on
future mitigation steps to take
including social gatherings to
especially protect those who are elderly
and those who are medically fragile as
you talked about in the opening here
there is a certain cohort of individuals
globally that are most at risk from
severe and critical medical conditions
as rising out of this novel coronavirus
and we need to take extra protections in
those environments to ensure infection
control and for those individuals to
stay away from settings that put them at
greater risk secretary aids are there's
also confusion about the corona virus if
you could we talked about this last hour
and we said we would ask you the corona
virus has been around for some time it's
the Cova Denine teen strain of the
corona virus that has caused
all of this all of these problems what
is it about that strain and what makes
that so different than the coronavirus
that has existed yes so there's a normal
corona virus a couple of strains of it
that exist and have existed for a long
time out in humanity our bodies are used
to dealing with them they have a known
profile in terms of morbidity and
mortality and they're all and people are
used to dealing with that SARS MERS and
now kovat 19 are genetic modifications
to that virus that the human body is not
used to dealing with does not have any
type of response mechanism built in for
it and has a particular severity of
mortality and morbidity profile
different from the common cold and as we
talked about in particular what we're
seeing is the elderly and individuals
who are medically fragile are most at
risk of severe and critical
complications from the disease
fortunately we're seeing that while
children and younger individuals can get
the disease globally the data seems to
be indicating that they are less at risk
of severe or critical complications from
the from the virus but we're continuing
to learn everyday then we're continuing
president Trump is going to insist that
we take aggressive measures in a
whole-of-government approach to protect
the public health here in the United
States as our first we've only got a
couple seconds left but we hear you
putting out a confident message one
where you say that the messaging is
coming from the White House is accurate
and all-inclusive we also hearing you
say that despite what we've heard from
other administration officials if you
want to test from the CDC you will get a
test nobody's being denied that what is
your biggest challenge your biggest
struggle right now in all of this our
biggest challenge right now is is to
ensure that we contain further spread
into the United States and that we work
with our state and local partners to
mitigate spread in areas where we've had
community spreading so that's working
with governor Inslee that's working with
Santa Clara County it's working with New
York State and City it's working with
Florida to take the aggressive measures
needed to slow down the spread of this
disease so that we can always continue
to buy time and mitt
the impact here in the United States but
make no mistake this is a very serious
health problem nobody is trying to
minimize that it is a very serious
public health threat to the people of
the United States and that's why
President Trump from day one has been
aggressive with a whole-of-government
approach and will continue to do so I
know I said last question but one more
there are schools open all over the
country some have decided to shut down
as a precaution do you recommend any
further school closings at the federal
level secretary azar based on what you
are seeing and hearing especially
considering the White House is now
limiting in-person meetings so we
haven't recommended that every single
community in America closed schools
we're working with individual
communities based on the data in their
community and what cases they have seen
in some communities closing schools is a
very appropriate measure in others it
might be having school but limiting
assemblies and larger gatherings within
the school so it's very much a local and
state decision about the approach to
take based on data we're there to help
and advise them
Alexei's our and the Health and Human
Services Secretary we know you're a busy
man thanks for spending some time right
appreciate it thank you